very fancy thank you very much indeed
for inviting us along to your other
swanky offices in Spain what's it like
to be gay 24th century Britain well it's
very different from when it was in the
early 90s when I came out at 13 at
school I think we've seen remarkable
progress over the last 20 years
particularly between kind of 2008 and
2018 was quite a big milestone in terms
of shifting attitudes so we saw rapid
legal change throughout the late 90s
early thousands and now really we're
starting to see that change attitudes
still lots to be done but it is a
remarkably a different place to be going
now are there any particular politicians
that you tip your cap to during that
decade well in the in the beginning it
was people like Lord Christmas
Angela regal really kind of pushing the
door so there were a lot of very brave
individuals who stood up and said I know
this isn't popular I know you're going
to be rude to me about it but I've got
to take a stand Ben Bradshaw was talking
yesterday about how he used to be
described as a deviant homosexual he was
likely to hurt the children in his
constituency do you know what I mean so
so that it took a lot of courage in
those days and I think what's really
inspiring now is that we see lesbian gay
and bisexual politicians across the
benches you know you look at you look at
the Conservative Party
you've got Justine greening you've got
Reece Davidson Margo James three
incredible women all open about their
sexuality on those conservative benches
and in the Conservative Party but I'm
guessing it's not just politicians who
are LGBT who supports the cause that I
am godmother to two little girls whose
parents are lesbian and they look to
David Cameron for gay marriage and him
changing the law I think it was him that
changed it was it was and although their
labor supporters they felt that you know
he had done his bit so it's not just
LGBT politicians who support you in back
in those early days when it wasn't very
popular so in those early 90s it was
there long BOCES now the fact that we
have such huge cross bench support and
support from heterosexual people
in general has been the real
game-changer you know people like my mom
doing her best in her sphere all the way
up to David Cameron doing his best in
his sphere it's people really making a
difference and we work with 750
employers and the drivers there really
are heterosexual people go and hold on a
minute
this is the right thing to do one lots
of different level I'm just looking
really recently did a survey didn't you
about business being more welcoming and
you know as a company's guy very proud
to be the top performing media company
Sky's doing really well and it there's a
misconception that media companies are
really good for LGBT people but some of
your competitors let's say struggle more
with this than others channel 4 adjuster
kind of trying to catch up with sky but
sky have really put the effort in over
the last couple of years particularly
around our rainbow Lacy's campaign and
supporting us with the sport work has
been really exciting to do tell us about
rainbow nation so rainbow ace is a
campaign we've been running for a couple
of years now we do it in partnership
with the Premier League where we work
with Premier League in September but all
sports in all different ways to
basically tackle homophobia in sport so
to basically say that prevalent is that
it's it's really quite prevalent in
football what we see in football there's
of course no openly gay players in the
Premier League at all but a lot of the
chants on the terraces we found has been
quite prolific so homophobic chants
banter just general kind of culture is a
real problem in other sports what we see
is that there's a reticence to to really
celebrate that you might have gay people
playing in your team and what sport is
struggling with is to realise that if
someone's not out that has an impact on
their performance so if someone's
keeping a secret they're holding back a
bit so from a sports psychology point of
view making sure people are able to be
themselves is a really important thing
it's what business worked out a decade
ago
you know you eyes IBM's Accenture they
don't do the gay stuff because it's a
nice thing to do they do it because it
makes good business sense I'm sure on
some level they like it but you know it
makes good business and sport hasn't
made that clique yet its fee for doing
enough I mean it's interesting that the
World Cup is in Russia and we know what
Russia's few is as far as gay
relationships
are concerned let alone LGBT how they
would feel about transgender different
thing they they're doing some things but
we would like them to do more I mean I
think that we would love to see that
some of the considerations about how
human rights defenders are treated in a
country are brought into play when these
decisions are made about where we host
World Cups saying that the activists in
Russia are really pleased that the
world's focus is now on Russia I think
what their concern is is that when the
cameras all go home and the folks going
home who's left watching them and
Stonewall does a huge amount of work
with human rights defenders in Russia
training them taking the 29 years of
stuff we've accumulated and saying don't
bother with that it didn't work very
well but that worked quite well and I
think that their concern is that this
focus is important but it needs to be
kept kept don't look fearful
yes yes of course with justification
yeah I mean I think the crackdown on
civil society organizations in Russia is
pretty extraordinary and I think that
people presume that hostility towards
LGBT people kind of manifests itself in
beating people up and there are elements
of that but when you take away money
when you take away spaces to meet when
you stop people meeting when you stop
people collecting stop people writing
literature performing plays all that is
an erosion of self and is a really
insidious indication of where our
nations are we're England right to take
part yes of course
and I don't think anyone would suggest
that English shouldn't go I think what's
what's important though is England
understand what role they have to play
in changing the culture here so when
those players go back to their teams
how can they be championing the end to
homophobia in sport more generally and I
think there is an increasing awareness
we're quite impressed by the the pace
with which sport has embraced the
campaign over the last couple years I'm
going back to politicians they have as
well this new strategy that's been
announced this week
banning conversion therapy but what is
that so lots of people talk about
conversion therapy I mean lots of
different things so what does it mean to
you so there's there's conversion
therapy where therapists might say you
think you're gay but you're not and I'm
going to I'm going to talk you out of
being gay that doesn't happen as much
anymore though it does still happen and
the regulatory bodies that govern
psychotherapy are very strict about that
what we're more concerned about
oh the informal conversions that are
going on behind closed doors in
communities in the name of God sometimes
or just in the name of any any deity
they want to pluck from the air it's
about trying to shame people and tell
them that they're not who they think
they are and the impact and the cruelty
on an individual's mental health and
well-being is is beyond the pale and I
know that there are some very upsetting
stories out there from people who've
experienced such things people like
Vicky beaching who's who's been talking
a lot this week about her experiences
and I think there's something very very
dark about some of the ways in which
young LGBT people are being treated by
their communities that needs attention a
Northern Ireland based group you've
probably heard about this that cancels
gay people says it will take legal
adviser the government bans conversion
therapy they say you can't force people
to be gay just because they have the
feelings what would you say
well I think this is what I mean by lots
of people mean different things about
conversion therapy we would fully expect
and welcome LGBT people going to speak
to good therapists about their feelings
about their sexual orientation and
gender identity I mean if only there was
more facilities available on the NHS
with people to do that and of course
people will go and talk about their arm
bivolo kneeling 'he's about that and
work it through and some might conclude
their LGBT some might not that's very
different to I'm gay please cure me
please stop me being gay and help me
stop being gay by by some pretty
barbaric practices so I think it is
about understanding that differentiation
what happens well kind of prayers over
people making them kind of stay up all
night to beat the demons out of them you
know kind of just really horrific stuff
that is very different - let's talk
about how you might feel I mean there's
a very different quality and I think
that people get over anxious about
people's capacity to have a good
conversation it's great people being
beaten up and told they're beating the
gay out of them and calling it
conversion therapy is not acceptable
certainly is not well with Northern
Ireland's just stay there for a moment
should with decision to provide pardons
for past convictions for gay men it's
the latest step but still a long way to
go in
is like Northern Ireland and of course
Island itself well Islands pretty good
actually
Islands further ahead than us these days
they're the creme de la creme and you go
that far yeah no they really that them a
Malta island of Malta other countries I
know yes strong Catholic countries
exactly it's really interesting that
both Malta and Ireland have said look
enough is enough we're gonna really
pursue this
so Island have got that of course they
did marriage but they've also got much
better legislation in relation to trans
equality for example they're much
further ahead Northern Ireland is
struggling and they're struggling with
marriage and they they have a majority
and I think they even have two-thirds
majority now but but they keep being
defeated by what's called this
conscience clause this veto and I think
the question for the activists in
Northern Ireland is what role can
Westminster play in helping that and I
think stone was very aware that the last
thing that we should do is rock up and
go don't worry the Brits are here we'll
sort all this out for you I mean that's
doesn't that's not the right way of
doing it but I think that we have a
really good opportunity in partnership
with the DEP that we currently hold to
try and do some influencing around that
and I think that I know that the people
of Northern Ireland are very very keen
for this to move forward we work with
employers in Northern Ireland and they
know that if they are training young
people in the universities in in Belfast
if they then leave and come to London
they've got a serious recruitment
problem and of course it's not just LGBT
people who say I don't want to live here
that you know Islands better London's
better why would I want to live here
it's there straight friends as well
you think hold on a minute I don't you
know so there's a real issue about
retaining the talent in country and
marriage is such a big litmus test
really for how our country stands and
all sorts of other issues as we saw in
Australia last year you kind of can take
a temperature quite well on how a
country feels about gay people getting
married
[Music]
seventy-five point government's strategy
it sounds very thorough wherever they
fallen short do you know they haven't
they we've been talking to them for a
long time 100,000 survey response gives
them a really good evidence base we've
said to them like these are the things
that are missing these are the really
urgent things these are things we'd like
to have these things are a bit more
tricky and they've gone okay so even
looking at things like surrogacy which
we thought wouldn't come up with this
Parliament to be frank you know
conservative minority government do you
want to be getting into the issue of
surrogacy they've said yet bring it on
so we're impressed how much they can
achieve of the seventy five points in
three years with four enough million is
thank heavens I'm nauseous I'm not
recording well you know it's a time of
austerity and money as shorts don't
stone was very good at doing a lot on a
little budget so I'm sure we can give
them some tips and a lot of it is about
just changing the narrative hate crime
action plan I I don't even live in a
London bubble when I was little I lived
in the North West I don't know if I had
forward-thinking parents but I've never
really particularly been aware of hate
crime against transgender or gay or
lesbian people that just I'm not saying
it's not there what I'm saying is has it
got better it feels like it hasn't I
think that all our evidence and it's a
bit of a blow to Stonewall because it's
our job to make this better but all our
evidence every five years shows that the
hate crime isn't going down or changing
what's interesting against gay people or
is it lesbians gays or is it more
transgender that's the issue both so
trans is much much higher so I think
it's about 50% of trans people of
experience hate crime so that's higher
than LGB and we split it up because
we're very aware that trans people are
having a very different time in terms of
hate crime so our own trans stuff can't
walk down the street without someone
heckling them and having a go at them
just just anecdotally here we know that
more and more of our staff or
experiencing hate crime some of our
staff for a festival the other week
we're leaving and a group of youth
started throwing rocks at him and his
friends you know these are these are
young game
should they deal with that they should
go to the police and I think that what
we said though you know if he's coming
out of a festival and somebody's
lobbying Rock Sookie what do you do well
I think what most LGBT people do these
days is the first thing they do is go on
social media so what's interesting is
that these stories are being told in a
different way I know that what I do when
I get called a dyke on the street and
you know gaff you know I found that even
in London I've been getting a lot of
stuff in the last year why I don't know
I think there's something there's
something a bit more edgy going on at
the moment I think a lot of the nation
been enabled because of brexit or
nothing to do it don't know I don't know
I think I think that people are angry
and people are taking that out in also
different ways I think that the
speculation about gender and gender
identity is fueling some of that so me
and my partner have both been asked to
leave bathrooms more in the last year
then we didn't we ever have so you know
who do you say they're in the wrong
toilet love well we're we're very good
humoured about it when we kind of say no
no no no we're right so we kind of be
quite gentle about it but but the
hostility is quite apparent and I think
that what we're seeing is people feel
more you know enabled to say stuff they
might have know ordinarily bitten their
tongue about and I think that's a bit to
do with social media because when it's
all going on on social media and care
you'll know better than me
quite how personal and bit trionic it
can get on social media how quickly that
can spill over into real life it doesn't
take much if someone's been emboldened
and has the confidence to say X Y and
said to me online doesn't take much for
them to say to me when they see me on
the street and you like me and probably
embrace that with a good humour and give
as good as we get but there are a lot of
people who are not strong characters as
real and it leaves a mark so even if you
decide to be quite resilient about it
and say well it's this and it's that and
it's just this person and it doesn't
really matter it will always leave a
mark even if you you're turning that
into something good that leaves a mark
and of course there are people out there
whose resilience is already eroded if
you're someone trans who's been you know
heckled on the street shouted out on the
bus your mum doesn't like you
your dad tells you that you know you
think you're on your freak then you get
online and someone has a go at you that
can be the last thing and I think we've
got to be really aware as a society
about how all this stuff accumulates
kind of really not just in relation to
LGBT stuff I think the way some women
are treated online the way black people
are treated online that there is
something that there's a cruelty to it
that is that is different I think than
what we've seen in the last few years
how difficult is it to come out really
difficult I think what most young people
do is they realize they're LGB in
particular and T and then wait and they
wait for about two to three years and in
those two to three years they wait for
every verbal cue to find out how things
are going to be is their mom going to be
alright about it or did she call Anthony
cotton on Coronation Street and all
you know every little thing like
that becomes a data gathering exercise
and you're assessing all the time how is
this going to be and what you risk is
you risk losing your family so they have
an expectation of how you're going to be
they have an anxiety that if you're
different what that's going to mean for
you they are worried about stigma
they're worried about it all might come
from a good place of love but the
individual has to risk losing their
support for that and that's changing
because parents are learning to say I
don't mind if you're gay by the way you
know and your Uncle John's gay and isn't
he great and I've got loads of got
children's you know they all grow up
with an T routine auntie Caroline who
brings them really cool they go and
Liberty clothes you know I mean so
there's a kind of the world is changing
but their anxiety is still very
prevalent particularly in young people
we we meet people who don't come out
until they're 22 23 when they've left
University have a job are secure then
they feel safe to come out and I still
work with people in their 50s and 60s I
was going to ask you about that the fact
that people have chosen one path like
Kelly Moloney lots of other people as
well and then at some stage in the
future realize that actually they wish
they're gone a different way
some people do other people don't those
that feel that they can't what would you
say to them I think that that people
have to do what's right for them in the
pace that's right for them but I think
that you cannot underestimate the impact
it has on your well-being to have a
secret
I think privacy is one thing but keeping
a secret is it can be toxic
some people and find someone to talk to
about it it doesn't mean you have to
smash everything well there are some
increasingly good resources out there
LGBT switchboard is fantastic you know
they're always there confidential
conversation the Samaritans are really
good at LGBT stuff these days sometimes
GPS can be good as well and there are
specialist service pink therapy has a
list of pink therapists but it is about
finding out the impact it's having on
you but not being yourself and realizing
you can kind of think about those issues
and then decide what you're going to do
about it it's people who say I'm going
to pretend this isn't happening who are
the who are the most harmed and that's
what always concerns us it's never about
everybody coming out and getting excited
it's about doing what's right for you
but recognizing the impact if you don't
pride what does what is pride mean to
you because obviously it's a bit
controversial that at the moment isn't
it as your organization is not overly
controversial in stable standards I mean
there are a hundred and forty prides in
Britain this year alone and every little
pride is amazing you go there are kids
there who have never been out before
buying their gay t-shirt for the first
time usually their mum and dad have come
with them on their little parade you
know it's it's really inspiring
so Stonewall has increasingly be doing
more and more local prides anyway so
we're doing 33 this year for the last
eight years we've done a lot with
something called UK black pride which is
an event that's just targeted at black
Asian and minority ethnic LGBT people
and it's incredible you know as a
community who are missed out of a lot of
the communications about gay issues not
reflected on television this event is
really powerful
something special is you come on K it's
really really special pride in London
used to work in partnership with them
and I think that we really wanted to
help pride in London have a better
working relationship with UK black pride
but that didn't quite come off so this
year in unity took Politis well I think
we just made the decision that this year
wasn't wasn't it wasn't the best use of
our time or priorities or resources you
know we could we've done it in the past
but I think that when the independent
advisory board said look pride in London
you've got some problems and probably
others said no we've not I think our
staff and our board fell
well alright you have a year to think
about it we'll do some other things and
let's let's kind of take it again
another time as you know people like the
European European pride are looking for
a public apology from you yes personally
would you like to give them one and I
think that what they're concerned about
is the fact that Stonewall raises money
and Stonewall has raised money for the
last 29 years we're by marketing and
Primark deal yeah and we've had deals
with lots of different organizations so
year before last we were partnering with
adidas yeah before that added us in
Primark can we particularly if the issue
because of what we created where it's
being created and they feel that the
funds should go to China to Turkey to my
and Maher as opposed to no I think they
want the funds to go to them just just
know so that's so that's what they want
the apology on I think that what we
we've decided to work with Primark
precisely because they work in those
areas so we have a global program where
we work with employers to influence
cultures locally because if Primark
creates an environment in Turkey where
LGBT people are able to be themselves
that's quite transformative you know
there's lots of ways to achieve change
we are thrilled that they want to give
us some proceeds from their sale of
Pride t-shirts last year they didn't
give that money to any charity at all
this year they chose us over local
prides and I think stone will always has
to make a decision about who we take
money from why and what the conditions
are around that and I think that for us
Primark are in a really good position to
influence and they want to support our
work internationally we train activists
in these countries to make change for us
to be able to introduce those activists
to people in Primark is a really strong
outcome some people will disagree with
that I am more than familiar with with
people sometimes disagreeing with the
decisions that stone will make but but
we make these decisions well and that's
how we work we rarely take government
money we've never taken government money
for core activity mainly because it was
never on offer so it became quite an
easy principle for us to adopt I
slightly regret that now okay if I'm
honest because it'd be quite nice to
take some government money yeah but so
we take it for projects but we don't
take it for court costs so we raised
money through lots of different forms
and people will disagree with that
sometimes what one message would you
like heterosexual people to take away
from this interview I think that it
would be great if heterosexual people
can recognize the power they have to
change culture so when the person next
to you says oh my god that computers so
gay just tell them they sound a bit of
an idiot because that kid is listening
to those cues as to whether they can
tell you they're LGBT or not doesn't
take much to change your culture at all
lovely to me and you thank you very much
thank you very much